superhero landing you're gonna do a
superhero landing wait for it
[Music]
and maximum effort here the music hey
everybody the unthinkable has happened
Disney has purchased most of 20th
Century Fox for 50 some odd billion
dollars so we have to react to this side
note if he didn't realize that Disney
now owns all the brands necessary to
make the Patton Oswalt version of Star
Wars that he did during that filibuster
before episode 7 came out they could
actually make that insane acid trip of a
movie now if they wanted they're not
gonna do it
but it'd be hilarious commander Luke
Skywalker now a full Jedi Knight
training new Padawans is using
ironically his father Anakin's red
lightsaber we pan outside of the control
a window to a nearby asteroid where we
see and please allow me to finish this
because it's gonna seem like a bit of a
jump we see fan OHS Ryan Reynolds
reacted to the news by posting these
photos like Deadpool getting kicked out
of Disneyland like God Disney doesn't
want Deadpool so they're probably gonna
keep him off as his own separate thing
we'll talk about that in a second he
also just confirmed the title of the
sequel is going to be the second coming
so I will do a separate Deadpool 2 video
later this week there's just so much
stuff to unpack with this big crossover
deal that it's gonna take a couple weeks
just a process at all there's a lot of
fine print and there's a lot of reasons
why Hollywood people are really upset
from business perspectives so we'll try
to explain what those are but there were
a lot of films that they were already
planning on making like Deadpool 3
x-force I'll try to explain what's going
to happen with those but if you're just
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
gonna be a whole bunch of infinity war
stuff happening but this is probably the
biggest comic book movie news that we've
had in the last couple of years the only
thing that could possibly top this is
that they announced Avengers 5 is going
to be Secret Wars and it'll be this big
combiner movie where you throw all those
characters in together so starting with
the big stuff first what's going to
happen in the next year or so the rest
of the Marvel phase 3 films in the next
phase of Fox films won't change they'll
make them
movies that they said that they were
going to make what they'll probably do
though like just a minor edit that
they'll add to the end of Avengers 4 is
just tease the idea of future x-men Fox
Deadpool stuff in the Marvel movies
without actually worrying about jamming
a bunch of characters in there if you
didn't know spider-man homecoming 2 is
the first official Marvel phase 4 film
they've only announced spider-man
homecoming 2 in guardians of the galaxy
3 during phase 4 everything else is a
complete mystery those are the films
that will change just a little bit
because of this new deal but that
doesn't mean that they're suddenly going
to start jamming all of the x-men
characters into the Marvel movies
because for the most part Fox Studios
like the people that actually produced
movies at Fox are staying on the lot
where they used to stay so literally
they're not moving anywhere it's not
like they're gonna move to the Disney
lot think about what Disney did with the
Marvel and the Pixar brands when they
bought them they became sort of their
own arms of Disney so they had a little
bit of Disney branding on them but for
the most part they make the films that
they want to make so Fox will just
continue to do that
you already see the Marvel fanfare in
front of all the x-men movies if you go
back and you watch the older Fox films
they still play that Marvel logo at the
beginning of all their films that's not
going to change what they'll probably do
when they're envisioning their next big
x-men movie after Dark Phoenix is
they'll find a way to tie them to Marvel
continuity in some small way so like
baby steps towards a crossover and then
when they build up to a big Avengers
film they'll use that as an opportunity
to legit cross an x-men character over
so what Marvel was already doing is they
were introducing all these new
characters like Captain Marvel you have
the wasp character that we're gonna get
cycled into The Avengers because other
characters are getting cycled out the
cool thing about the x-men franchise is
that they have most of the cool female
characters there are a lot of people
that are asking about the Fantastic Four
because they would be perfect in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so I think
that eventually we will get a Marvel
version of a Fantastic Four movie or
you'll see them try to use one of the
Fantastic Four characters inside a
Marvel movie
part of the reason people are freaking
out though is because of the Deadpool
franchise it's been amazing it's hard
are and not something that Disney is
known for doing they don't make a whole
lot of rated at our films there was a
really weird statement that Bob Iger
who's the man in charge at Disney right
now said that they're really interested
in making more Deadpool rated our films
they're like if people really want that
we'll give that to them as long as they
know what they're getting so what
they're saying is is from a marketing
standpoint they make more Deadpool rated
our films they just make sure to market
them so that people know that they're
going to see it rated our film part of
the funniest thing about that first
Deadpool movie was listening to people
with families take their little kids
then sing the way they reacted when it
started to get nuts there are a lot of
my movie critic internet friends that
are very pessimistic about this deal
like they're not gonna make more
Deadpool movies it's not gonna happen I
totally think that they will it's just
that from a marketing standpoint they'll
try to present them as their own
separate thing so I don't think that
you're gonna see Deadpool crossing over
with the Avengers anytime soon because
Avengers MCU is firmly in Disney
territory from a creative perspective so
I think that they'll just tried to put
Deadpool off by himself they'll still do
x-force it's sort of the Deadpool
version of an x-men movie like a hard-r
x-men movie and they'll just sell them
as their adult brand like you have Sony
that still got the spider verse so just
because Marvel bought the rights to Fox
doesn't mean that it changes anything
with the spider-man characters over at
Sony Sony's getting ready to make their
rated-r version of a spider-man universe
the spider verse is going to be way more
hardcore than if it were at Disney
so they'll still be a lot of that
happening but until they actually have
an x-men character pop up in a Marvel
film there's gonna be a lot of confusion
so what'll probably happen is is that at
Comic Con this next year they'll do a
big Marvel panel where Kevin Feige will
talk about x-men characters so you get
some more information but maybe not
right away
so just let me know what you guys think
about this there are potential pitfalls
to this deal but I think as long as
Disney lets Fox be its own brand by
itself and then every once
while across the characters over and
then maybe like a Secret Wars movie down
the road I think from a comic book movie
perspective things will be fine
there's other business things that might
arise like the fact that Disney becomes
a monopoly but that's like a whole
separate business thing but what's gonna
happen later tonight is I'll post some
new Star Wars the last Jedi make sure
you go see the film so that we can talk
about everything there's a lot of big
twists that we needed to talk about
there's a new round of that imax ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video congratulations to the winner
from my last video Adam Anna please
private message me so I can get your
contact details there'll be a new round
when I post a new video later tonight
you can click here for my non-spoilery
Star Wars the last Jedi review and you
can click here to learn all about the
new spider-man venom movie inside the
spider-verse
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]